all right for a hundred thousand dollars
from reno but unfortunately not at the
live event jacob g
so give jacob a round of applause
and from henderson and here with us
tonight
please come join us up on the stage
audrey s
[Applause]
that's wonderful
oh she did okay
congratulations
you're
amazing congratulations
we do
thank you
and now
[Applause]
to our 250 000 quarter of a million
dollar cash winner
someone's going to be a quarter of a
million dollars richer after tonight if
i could ask my friend senator jackie
rosen could you please come up here and
do the honors of revealing our winner
tonight
well thank you governor this is so
exciting
and i'm saying the envelope please and
the winner of 250 000 from getting
vaccinated from here in las vegas
loretta
[Applause]
you look excited
congratulations thank you
vet congratulations
that leaves our final one million dollar
grand prize winner
and i think this person has probably
already figured out that they won a
million dollars so i won't waste any
time opening an envelope for this one
our one million dollar
grand prize winner and our newest
millionaire
hey liam p of las vegas you are one
million dollars richer
[Applause]
come on over
our newest millionaires
[Applause]
no